[ __ ] God Lola Lola ashton kutcher and
mila kunis just put their own adorable
spin on a classic children's song and
it's pretty epic thank you that was very
sweet
the parents of do posted a sweet video
of themselves singing lalala in the
black-and-white clip Ashton and Mila are
seen belting out the popular song while
hanging out in their kitchen while their
children are heard playing along in the
background and we're still in love like
it's a you high-five would you still
like each other and used to like your
kid at the end of the night Ashton
captured the sweet video quote Kutcher
sing-along
hashtag beat children's song hashtag
lavaca Lola it's cute it's very sweet
but it seems that not everyone was
impressed with the kitchen concert
people who are really honestly had your
best interest in mind and are gonna tell
you the truth in comments all the time
zoe saldana hilariously trolled the
couple commenting on their post quote
hahahahahahaha you guys can do better
than that
come on bring it on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]